this video is sponsored by longevity
technology
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video we're
going to talk all about telomeres
and the role that telomeres play in the
aging process
so we'll begin by looking at what
telomeres are so that will be in terms
of the molecular underpinnings of
telomeres
and then we'll look at the implications
of telomere shortening
at the cellular level and what happens
to cells when they have short telomers
and then we'll extend this further by
looking at the organismal level and some
of the mouse models that have been used
to investigate this and then we'll look
at the current evidence
that shows links between telomere
shortening and the aging process
and then lastly we'll address the
question of whether increasing telomere
length could be beneficial
and look at some of the strategies in
which this could be achieved
so let's begin with the fundamentals
what actually are telomeres
well the name derives from greek with
telos meaning
enz and meros meaning part talking about
the end part
the end part of what well telomeres
refer to the end parts of
dna and so dna contains all the genetic
information that makes us
us and that genetic information is
stored within the nucleus of a cell
and so dna contains the four different
nucleotides
adenine guanine thymine and cytosine and
our dna contains more than three billion
base pairs and the way that this is
organized within a cell
is in separate linear chromosomes
so the important word to take from that
for this video is the word linear
the dna has a linear structure which
means it has
ends and so you might think well big
deal who cares
well there are actually several reasons
firstly due to the way in which dna is
replicated
every time a cell divides it has a
so-called end replication problem
and this is due to the nature of the
polymerases and rna templates that are
used to synthesize dna
and basically what happens is that one
of the strands of dna
isn't fully replicated and so it's an
end replication problem because
each time the dna is replicated a
fragment of it gets lost
and so this results in progressive
chromosomal shortening
and so this would be particularly bad if
these ends of chromosomes contain genes
that
are important for the cell to survive
but instead
what's at the end of dna are these
tandem repeats of
six nucleotide sequences in humans the
sequence is
tta ggg and so telomeres just refer to
these repetitive sequences
found at the end of dna and these
sequences are actually wrapped up in a
protein complex called sheltering
and this sheltering complex is actually
really important because it hides the
ends of dna out of sight
from the dna damage response machinery
within a cell that would otherwise
recognize the ends of the dna
as a double stranded break and try and
fuse two ends back together which could
end up in some
interesting fragments of chromosomes
which isn't good
and so for these reasons telomeres are
often described as being like the shoe
caps at the end of your shoelaces
like how she caps protects the the laces
from unthreading
the telomeres help to maintain
chromosomal stability
so each time i cell divides these
telomeres are going to get shorter
because of the end replication problem
interestingly though work conducted by
elizabeth blackburn
carol greider and jack shostak
discovered the enzyme telomerase
that can actually extend telomeres and
prevent them from shortening over time
and this work led to them being awarded
the nobel prize in physiology or
medicine
in 2009 and so the interesting thing
about telomerase is that it's a
ribonucleoprotein complex
and what that means is that there's a
protein component of telomerase
and there's also a rna component which
explains the ribone nuclei parts
and so the protein component that has
the enzymatic activity to
synthesize these telomeric repeats is
known as telomerase refers transcriptase
or tarts
and then the other important aspect is
this rna component
which is what mediates the recognition
of the complex to the telomeres
and that's the rna component known as
telomerase
rna component tuc so we have tarte and
tarc and this makes up telomerase
now the reason i went into so much
detail was because we'll come back to
this later on when we look at strategies
of extending telomeres and that's
because a majority of cells
telomerase isn't expressed and so
actually the telomeres shorten over time
so this brings us on to looking at the
cellular level implications of telomere
shortening
and how it relates to the aging process
the best way to explain this is with the
graph i am drawing out now
the x-axis represents the number of
divisions a cell has undergone
whilst the y-axis shows the length of
the telomeres
as we've discussed the length of
telomeres in the absence or minimal
telomerase activity
will decrease over time since telomeres
are important for maintaining chromosome
stability
and cell function when their length
reaches a telomere length limit
the cell stops dividing and enters
so-called replicative senescence
this is a cell state whereby the cell is
still active
but it's just not dividing and this
limits you may have already heard of
before
is called the hayflick limit after
leonard hayflick who noticed that normal
human cells
stopped dividing after replicating
around 50 times
cells that break through this limit and
keep dividing
reach the next stage referred to as
crisis by this stage the telomeres have
become so short the sheltering complexes
collapse
dna ends get exposed and get fused
together aberrantly
and chromosome mayhem and shoes
basically
now there are two outcomes from this one
the cell will die
or two the cell can reactivate
telomerase
and restore telomere lamps or achieve
this by alternative mechanisms
and continue dividing but now the cell
has got mixed up dna
and accumulated different mutations so
when these cells divide results in
uncontrolled growth which can result in
tumor genesis
so what's this got to do of aging well
the accumulation of senescent cells
and the risk of developing cancer
increase with age
moreover the reduced ability of cells to
replicate
from telomere shortening can reduce
regenerative potential
and repair of different tissues and so
this is where we now come to the
organismal level and some mouse studies
that support the link between telomere
shortening and aging
so to study this link mouse models have
been made
whereby mice lack telomerase activity so
either the mice lack the gene encoding
tart or tug the protein or rna
components of telomerase that i
mentioned earlier and in both cases
loss of telomerase which causes telomere
dysfunction
resulted in a shortened life expectancy
aged appearance decline in tissue stem
cell reserves and reduced capacity to
cope with injury
and to further prove causality between
telomere length from aging
the opposite experiments have been done
whereby mice lacking telomerase activity
have had the activity restored which
then was seen to restore telomere length
and reversed
tissue degeneration including the testes
spleen and intestines
and so the way that they do this in
these mouse models is they have
genetically modified mice
that have tart expression that can be
controlled by the presence of a drug
and we also have evidence from human
studies as well
in particular from patients who have
telomere pathies
whereby they have mutations in the genes
encoding tart and tuck but also
other proteins that are involved in
regulating the maintenance of telomeres
and patients with these conditions are
shown to have many different aging
phenotypes
such as depletion of hematopoietic stem
cells which can lead to bone marrow
failure
immunosenescence of lymphocytes so white
blood cells
and increased incidence of idiopathic
pulmonary fibrosis
liver cirrhosis and kidney diseases and
so that 2011 nature paper that i
recently showed you
whereby they restore telomerase activity
and hmis that had short telomeres
suggest that reactivating telomerase is
potentially a promising
anti-aging strategy but would increasing
telomere length
actually be beneficial and how would it
potentially be achieved
so unsurprisingly given the link between
telomere dysfunction
and hallmarks of aging there has been
much interest in
telomerase restoration therapies as
potential
anti-aging strategies and for treatment
of patients with telomeres
the obvious approach is to activate tart
or turk activity
either at the gene expression level or
by enhancing the activity of the protein
itself for example small molecules have
been identified
to activate heart including ta-65
also known as cyclostragonal and histone
diocese laser inhibitors
however the mechanism of action of these
compounds seems quite unclear at the
moment
plus there's quite limited clinical
trial data
moreover there seems to be interest in
hormonal agents such as danazole and
5-alpha dihydrotestosterone
but again only very early work has been
conducted
and so it all seems quite inconclusive
at the moment
alternative approaches would be to have
transient ectopic expression of tart
either by using viral factors or
modified
rna but one of the issues with these
approaches is getting widespread tissue
exposure
and to get them to target stem cells
which are the regenerative cells of the
body
another approach that i think is quite
cool is to stabilize tuck
so remember that this is the rna
component of telomerase
and so tuck gets tagged for degradation
by protein
pap d5 and a study that came out last
year
identified a small molecule inhibitor of
this protein which they showed in a
study to extend telomeres of cells and
culture
as well as showing it to be well
tolerated in mice for
several months so what are the potential
concerns of these strategies
well ultimately one concern is that it
could potentially drive a cell that has
entered
crisis and allow it to escape by
reactivating telomerase activity
and this could therefore increase the
cancer risk
and this is supported by the fact that
telomerase inhibitors are being
investigated as
anti-cancer strategies so what would an
optimal strategy be
well given the potential hazard of
increasing the telomeres of cancerous
cells
or cells that are in crisis or making
tumor growth more aggressive
it would seem that a good strategy would
have transient telomerase induction
which hopefully would be less likely to
fuel cancer grave
that could result from having
constitutive telomerase expression
but in reality our understanding of how
telomerase activity is controlled and
regulated in a cell
and how that balance of over and under
activity
is controlled is still incomplete and
many knowledge gaps still remain
for example further understanding the
non-canonical functions
of the telomerase complex and the
interplay between
telomere dysfunction and pathological
processes such as
inflammation fibrotic and degenerative
diseases
is needed so i think this quote from
elizabeth blackburn
nicely summarizes the complexity of the
fields that
aging is so many different things and
cells being able to sell from you
is part of the picture but not all of it
and so there is still ongoing interest
in these telomerase reactivation
strategies
but it's also evident that much more
workers needed to further investigate
this and to really evaluate
the potential risks so hopefully this
video has given you some insight into
how telomeres fit into the aging process
and why understanding their regulation
by telomerase may aid
potential interventions for aging so
with that i'd like to thank the sponsor
for this week's video longevity
technology
longevity technology delivers high
quality daily news and
insights on research investments and
technologies that extend health span
and lifespan find the link to their
website in the description
so i hope you've learned something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters
and thank you for listening